So games are complicated.
They often end up being way
more code than you expect.
So to get an idea why,
let's try breaking down a classic game
into it's components,
and it's behaviors.
If you haven't played Tetris,
go play it like right now.
It's an essential part
of gaming history.
If you just google for Tetris,
you'll find a dozen versions
you can play online for free.
Let's do an object oriented
analysis of Tetris.
What we're going to do is write down
a paragraph describing exactly how
Tetris works.
Then we're going to underline all
of the nouns to get an idea of what
classes we might need
to implement Tetris.
Then we'll underline all the verbs
to get an idea what methods those
classes might need.
So, what is Tetris?
Tetris is a game where
colored Tetriminos,
that's the technical term,
fall down a field of play
until they collide with
the previously placed Tetrimino.
As a Tetrimino is falling, the user can
rotate it and can drop it into place.
Once a Tetrimino comes to rest,
if a line of blocks in
the field of play is complete.
It is removed, and all blocks
placed above it are moved down.
Removing a line earns points.
Points are displayed on a scoreboard,
along with a preview
of the next tetromino.
Now that's a super cursory
description But even here we have
a bunch of classes we would need
in order to implement the game.
We would need a game class to
set everything in motion and
coordinate the rest of the actors.
We would need a class for the falling
tetromino to represent its position and
its rotation and also what shape it is.
We would need a field of play to
represent where all the blocks are and
to put the tetromino somewhere.
Speaking of attributes of the tetromino,
you probably also want
a class to represent colors, scanning
through some more for some more nouns.
We find blocks, all right.
So we might want a class for blocks or
perhaps blocks is just
part of the field of play.
I don't know it's hard to
say how to design it best.
Then we see we have points.
We need a class to represent
how many points we have.
We'd also need a scoreboard
to display those points and
we need this whole preview pane thing.
Now let's scan through for
some verbs to find what methods
these various classes would need.
So the tetrominos need
to know how to fall.
The tetrominos also need to know
how to rotate and how to drop.
Some class needs to know when
a tetromino collides with blocks that
are already in the field of play, maybe
the tetromino's responsible for that,
maybe the field of play
is responsible for that.
Then there's this concept
of coming to rest,
where a falling tetromino just turns
into blocks in the field of play.
Scanning through some more,
we need a way to remove lines of
blocks from the field of play.
We need a way to move down
blocks after a line is removed.
Then there's the fact that all of this
needs to know how to draw itself, and
that's a big task.
So again, this is just a short
description of Tetris, and
an incredibly simple analysis of it.
We could keep going here.
Point is, games are complicated.
And decomposing them into their
component parts is essential to making
any headway in actually
implementing them.